the 2017 Sakharov Prize for freedom of  thought goes to Venezuela's Democratic  opposition and political prisoners the  prizes to be awarded to the winners in  Strasbourg  ahead of a crucial European summit  Parliament discusses the current state  of play with BRICS if negotiations  including sticking points in the talks  like the Northern Irish border  area peas vote on the final  recommendations of the parliaments  Committee of Inquiry set up after the  Panama leaks they suggest measures to  counter money laundering and tax evasion  members of parliament vote on the  extension of the European fund for  strategic investments an extension could  mobilize up to 500 billion euros and  investments by 2020 fostering job  creation a  vote is foreseen on whether to permit  phosphates in Chabad meets Parliament  votes on the Commission's proposal